at 42 again gets color with a nice move
on hardened gives it up
Thompson for three yes and that's twice
for individual one-on-one defense by
game Karnataka by sin abacus USA Today
convention that warrior
as the lamp is able to knock down the
baseline jump another three-point
attempt rebounded by Durant
style one-on-one basketball Houston
shots of Golden State and the beautiful
thing about the isolation is the rat
knocks that down best home record in the
Western Division tied with how does the
best in the NBA a seven another brings a
tough shot you agency
go inside and kind of come back out
mid-range Durant with whom hits the play
so Kevin Durant off to the good star he
has nine points
well hist endeavor has a problem running
a job from three-point link to ran out
of a that he is real hot and Iguodala
for Durant
hazardous
and the dollar fires yes
[Applause]
[Music]
don't write everything young with wish
and leave upfront
nice play will backdoor for Thompson
Thompson and Livingston in the man-whore
Thompson got the step on Anderson finds
lon yes
[Applause]
second from downtown the laptop
[Applause]
puts the move on Paul Vincent's way
[Applause]
easy money
Ramon Green who has had a sensation of
playoff whoa
what is this shy of a triple trouble
editor we're here
who has had a sensational playoff one
what is this shy of a triple double an
attorney
put that by Thompson is fouled
[Applause]
time
need on the offensive and is your big
from the company and cleaning up the
class after all we got these to the
halls
in France him
the center gets 65% of Kevin Durant here
tonight
so it's Golden State please point Wayne
for a quick toss it off the beautiful
pass
[Music]
puts the move on heart
[Applause]
I'm gonna have to try to low block that
this is no way that you're even gonna
put a hand in his back laughing play
possum fella falsify that goes out of
Kevin Durant is not discriminating
[Music]
Thompson 4:40 about the Warriors
attention 11-point lead first appearance
for adonai not played much did these
playoffs at the right able to hit over
the next curve
[Music]
so that he would be the health defender
will take Thompson one I know
so style again but everyone
watching Thompson from downtown yes
Thaksin the 687 it's for the Warriors
this duster shuttle yes
the best news is for nobodies in Houston
got back past half court on that
defensive play okay